dire que ils ont inventé les routes de
la drogue bien avant que les entreprises
ne découvrent les bienfaits de la
mondialisation on ne visualise pas à
quel point ça peut être compliqué de se
retrouver avec dans son garage montagnes
de billets de banque comme ça il faut en
faire quelque chose l'argent sale
devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardants
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dit aux nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
le gouvernement ouvre un peu à peu la
vaccination au plus grand nombre dès
demain que les adultes qui souffrent de
maladies chroniques pourront recevoir
l'injection antico vide à partir du 15
juin ce sont tous les français de plus
de 18 ans qui auront accès aux vaccins
tu annonces des manuels macro alors que
les mutations du cornât virus préoccupe
au moins cinq cas de variole indiens ont
été détectés sur le territoire
[Musique]
au brésil l'épidémie a fait plus de
quatre cent mille morts la gestion de la
situation sanitaire par le gouvernement
de jaillir à bolton arrow est décrié le
président brésilien objet d'une enquête
parlementaire depuis mardi à manaus en
amazonie où le variant brésilien est
apparu la pénurie d'oxygène avait
provoqué la mort de dizaines de patients
par asus
[Musique]
la colère de ces palestiniens après
l'annoncé du report des élections
législatives les premières depuis 15 ans
elle était très attendue par la
population
le président de l'autorité palestinienne
renvoie la faute sur israël sont
garanties sur la tenue des élections à
jérusalem est pas de scrutin c'est ce
qu'à décréter mahmoud abbas
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les indicateurs
épidémiologique à la baisse en france à
la proche du déconfinement mais la
situation reste délicate avec plus de
5600 malade encore hospitalisés en
réanimation et le variant indien du
coronavirus inquiète plus que jamais
cinq cas ont été identifiés en métropole
c'est dans ce contexte qu emmanuel
macron annonce l'ouverture de la
vaccination à tous les français majeurs
à partir du 15 juin
dès demain restera accessible aux
adultes souffrant de maladies chroniques
4 millions de personnes fragiles sont
concernés encore faut-il trouver des
doses l'équité territoriale est pointé
du doigt
bassem chebbi et si les zones les plus
touchées de france n'étaient pas les
mieux servis par la vaccination
malgré un rythme des injections à la
hausse avec plus de 20 millions déjà
réalisés
les écarts de répartition des doses à
l'échelle des départements montre que le
gouvernement oublier une fois encore les
plus précaires dans la lignée du constat
établi lors du premier confinement en
termes d'inégalités les territoires les
plus fragiles ceux là même où le virus
circule encore à vitesse grand v demeure
encore et toujours les grands perdants
il suffit pour cela de se pencher
quelques instants sur les statistiques
départementales en date du 21 avril la
seine-et-marne comptait 12 5% de
personnes vaccinées contre 28 36 en
corse-du-sud encore 24,7 en ariège d'une
manière générale lé département à
dominante rurale est faiblement peuplées
sont les plus avancés à la verse les
zones urbaines d'honneur à la traîne
pourtant elles les autorités sanitaires
affirment que la répartition des doses
et rééquilibrer en fonction de l'état
sanitaire des territoires encore une
fois on constate que la réalité sur le
terrain est tout autre
le département du rhône par exemple où
le taux d'incidence était de 420
nouveaux cas pour 100000 habitants la
semaine du 21 avril a été moins bien
doté que le territoire de belfort où le
taux d'incidence était pourtant
inférieure
si on rapporte le nombre de doses vivre
et à la population départementale et à
la situation épidémique
on observe que des départements très
fortement touchée reçoivent
proportionnellement moins
dawes que d'autres où la situation est
plus favorable à l'image de la
seine-saint-denis et de la scène et m'a
donné la priorité aux personnes d'un
certain âge peut-on effet posé problème
quant à l'efficacité de la nuit contre
le coc u19
si on exclut de cette stratégie le
facteur économique et social dans les
zones les plus pauvres où le virus
circule le plus le gouvernement a choisi
de ne pas garder le critère de pauvreté
dans sa stratégie vaccinale on peut que
le regretter
le taux de vaccination population
générale n'a pas beaucoup de sens
même si la cible se concentre sur les
personnes âgées la part des vaccinés est
en seine et marne et en seine saint
denis plus faible que dans la creuse ou
dans le doubs car ce sont des
départements plus jeune alors que la
moyenne d'âge en réanimation à l'échelle
nationale est d'environ 60 ans elle est
en seine-saint-denis de 47 ans pour
avoir une limite est élevé il faut un
pourcentage de vaccinées élevées en
faisant l'impasse sur de nombreux
facteurs notamment économiques et
sociaux le gouvernement semble décidé à
maintenir la feuille de route du
président de la république quitte à
creuser un peu plus les disparités dont
les départements les plus touchés se
serait bien passé le gouvernement qui
fait le choix d'un déconfinement
progressif en quatre phases dépendant
toutefois de la situation sanitaire
première étape lundi avec la levée des
restrictions de déplacement
il faudra attendre la fin du mois de
juin pour retrouver une vie presque
normale
scarlett bas je me retrouve la joie et
la bonne humeur
cette restauratrice peut se réjouir
dès le 19 mai elle pourra accueillir sur
sa terrasse des tables de six personnes
dès cette date les français pourront à
nouveau partager un verre assister à une
séance de cinéma un spectacle ou encore
visiter un musée et ce jusqu'à 21h le
couvre-feu est en décalé de deux heures
mais d'autres professionnels du secteur
de la restauration pensent à leurs
collègues qui n'ont pas les mêmes
capacités d'accueil
aujourd'hui on est content de démarrer
avec les terrasses malheureusement il ya
toute une partie des établissements sont
majoritaires qui n'ont pas de terrasse
donc il faut quand même rapidement qu'on
rouvre l'intérieur ce sera la deuxième
étape celle du 9 juin
les restaurants et les cafés pourront
accueillir de nous
des clients à l'intérieur en respectant
un protocole à ce jour pas encore arrêté
de leur côté les plus sportifs pourront
retrouver leurs alter et leurs tapis
roulant dans leur salle de sport le
couvre-feu lui sera décalée à 23 heures
mais pour les plus noctambules pas de
perspective de retrouver les pistes de
danse
les discothèques sont les grandes
oubliées de ce plan de réouverture on
est fermé depuis 13 mois et on n'a
aucune perspective d'ouverture donc là
on attend une chose est sûre c'est pas
nous qui avons propager le virus
puisqu'un est fermé depuis treize mois
après on nous parle de passes sanitaire
nous je sais qu'à l'entrée des
discothèques les entrées sont contrôlés
au niveau des indices d identité et au
niveau des âges donc contrôlés
d'identité ou des âges on peut contrôler
au 6 impasse sanitaire donc c'est
largement faisable
emmanuel macron a en effet tranché la
question du passé ni terre le président
ne veut pas qu'il soit obligatoire pour
les restaurants mais il souhaite le
rendre nécessaire pour l'accès au stade
festival ou fois des événements qui
pourront se tenir dès le 9 juin et
accueillir jusqu'à 5000 personnes sur
présentation du sésame
ces restrictions pourrait s'alléger
début juillet après une saison 2009 un
sens festival la perspective est pour
cet été plus optimiste si bon espoir
quand même que tous les festivals de cet
été reste vivant et reste comme ça en
capacité de 2 ne jaillit ray de donner à
la population un peu de joie et de
réanimation
la plupart sont quand même en plein air
ou presque je vois pas vraiment la
possibilité qu aujourd'hui on dise on
est en lui et on les arrête le
gouvernement prévient que son plan de
déconfinement est sujet à caution
il sera révisé toutes les trois semaines
pour l'adapter si besoin aux évolutions
de la situation sanitaire
si aucun grain de sable ne vient
s'immiscer dans ce mécanisme
la dernière étape attendue est celle du
30 juin qui marquera la fin du
couvre-feu
et alors que l'europe dans son ensemble
se prépare à sortir de la crise le
brésil lui si on fonce l'épidémie a déjà
fait plus de quatre cent mille morts
dans le pays un seuil symbolique qui a
donné lieu à une manifestation sur la
célèbre plage de copacabana à rio
des activistes ont déposé 400 sacs
mortuaires symbolisant chacun à 1000
victimes du coc vide
ils dénoncent la gestion de la situation
sanitaire par le gouvernement de jacques
bolle sonar au le président brésilien
cible d'une enquête parlementaire elle a
été ouverte ce mardi grâce d'ailleurs
des cimetières plein dans tout le pays
ici à sao paulo les familles endeuillées
ne cesse d'enterrer leurs morts pour le
seul mois d'avril le pays déplore cent
mille morts dus qu'aux vives 19
et encore si chiffre serait sous-évalué
selon de nombreux experts
pourtant aucune annonce de confinement
longue durée à l'horizon de la part du
gouvernement
par conséquent la ville et ses métros
sont toujours bondée j'ai peur et nous
sommes tous très inquiet j'essaie
d'éviter de sortir les gens ont besoin
de se déplacer pour manger quelle serait
la bonne solution
ils devraient tous fermés pendant deux
mois pour voir si les cas diminue mais
il continue de le faire tous les quinze
jours c'est inutile ça ne marchera pas
et avec ces nouveaux variants qui
arrivent ici ça va être pire
malgré l'urgence la vaccination peine à
s'accélérer
la campagne a débuté mi janvier avec les
vaccins astrazeneca et corona vac jeudi
soir un million de doses pfizer sont
arrivés dans les pays mais pour le
vaccin rue spoutnik v attendu par de
nombreux états pour accélérer le
mouvement
l'homologation est toujours en débat une
lenteur dont le brésil se serait bien
passé tant le gouvernement est déjà la
cible de critiques internes en raison
d'une stratégie sanitaire qui suscite
l'incompréhension mardi au sénat une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire a été
mise en place
objectif déterminer la responsabilité de
l'état et notamment celles déjà erbol
sonar au qui ne semble pas déstabiliser
un responsable
hier les responsables et ceux qui sont
coupables d'action d'omission de
négligence ou d'incompétence et si cela
est prouvé ils seront tenus pour
responsables ce sera la réponse pour
nous reconnecter avec la planète les
crimes contre l'humanité n'expire jamais
et son transnationaux ils sont pleins je
ne suis pas inquiet au sujet de cette
enquête
je ne suis pas inquiet parce que nous ne
sommes redevables de rien mais la
situation politique demeure sous tension
d'autant que dans l'hémisphère sud
l'entrée dans l'hiver approche et fait
craindre une diffusion accrue du virus à
laquelle s'ajoute la multiplication des
variants avec quatre cent mille morts
pour 212 millions d'habitants le brésil
est le deuxième pays le plus endeuillé
au monde après les états unis et autres
pays où la situation sanitaire est
dramatique
l'inde chaque jour le niveau de
contamination bat des records l'aide
internationale commence à arriver les
premières cargaisons en provenance des
états unis ont atterri ce vendredi à new
delhi de l'équipement pour les hôpitaux
un million de tests de dépistage du
coronavirus et surtout plus de 400
bouteilles d'oxygène le pays en manque
cruellement
comment en est-il arrivé là explications
en images
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
m
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et inquiétude également en turquie jeu
face à la recrudescence des quatre co
vide chaque jour les chiffres explosent
parfois jusqu'à 40000 contamination
quotidienne en ce mois d'avril
depuis hier le pays est donc totalement
est strictement confiné pour trois
semaines françois tatti skavich trafic
presque habituelle sur le pont du
bosphore ce vendredi matin à istanbul
mais dans les rues de la plus grande
ville du pays rares sont les
stambouliotes à s'y aventurer
seuls quelques touristes semblent
s'accommoder de la situation
à istanbul il ya tellement de choses à
voir que ça n'a pas tellement
d'importance qui est un conte fini pour
les touristes c'est bon ils regardent
nos passeports ils disent vous êtes
libre
donc je ne me soucie pas du confinement
un confinement jusqu'au 17 mai qui fait
suite à une explosion du nombre des cas
quotidiens
cette semaine près de 40000 sont
enregistrées chaque jour
poussant le président recep tayyip
erdogan à réagir et prendre des mesures
iman a lot
hormis les secteurs de la production de
l'industrie de l'alimentation du
nettoyage de la santé qui connaîtront
des exceptions les activités de tous les
lieux de travail seront suspendus tous
les déplacements entre les villes seront
soumis à des autorisations spéciales et
les moyens de transports publics ne
pourront y fonctionner qu'à 50% de leurs
capacités mais une mesure fait polémique
l'interdiction de la vente d'alcool
pendant le confinement que ce soit en
grande surface ou dans les magasins de
spiritueux en plein mois sacré musulman
du ramadan
cette décision a provoqué la colère de
nombreux turcs laïque voyant une
tentative du président r doan
d'instaurer un style de vie religieux à
la société
pourquoi enfermer vous les gens et
interdisez vous l'alcool les gens qui ne
peuvent pas sortir ont trouvé des
alternatives et fabriquent eux mêmes
leur alcool à la maison vous ne pouvez
pas l'arrêter la turquie est un pays
laïc
il a toujours été ils profitent de la
situation pour dire aux gens reprenez
vos esprits et écoutez nous interdisant
l'alcool et d'autres choses nous
augmentons le prix des cigarettes
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça sur le
fond de la vaccination
la turquie est confronté à une pénurie
de doses le ministre de la santé a
annoncé cette semaine avoir signé un
accord pour recevoir 50 millions de
doses du vaccin russe poutine clé dans
les six prochains mois avec un premier
arrivage prévu pour le mois de mai
depuis le début de la campagne de
vaccination en janvier dernier plus de
22 millions de doses de vaccins de
pfizer et sinovac ont été administrés en
turquie au total moins de 9 millions de
personnes ont été entièrement vacciner
pour ce pays qui compte près de 84
millions d'habitants ils protestent
contre leur report des élections
législatives à l'appel du hamas une
foule de palestiniens se sont rassemblés
dans les territoires occupés comme ici à
jabalia ils dénoncent la décision de
mahmoud abbas sont présentés deux dates
alternative le président de l'autorité
palestinienne a annoncé le report du
scrutin
rejetant la responsabilité sur israël
les détails avec hélène masquelier les
premières élections prévues depuis une
quinzaine d'années un souffle
démocratique sur les territoires
palestiniens mais qui pourrait ne jamais
voir le jour
les votes étaient prévues le 22 mai pour
les législatives et en juin
yep pour la présidentielle un calendrier
qui est mise à mal par de violents
affrontements qui secouent jérusalem est
depuis maintenant deux semaines
en marge de ces heurts israël a
interpellé plusieurs des candidats aux
législatives
poussant le président palestinien a
tranché devant cette difficile situation
nous avons décidé de reporter la date
des élections jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait une
garantie que jérusalem et son peuple
puisse participer à ces élections
il n'y aura donc aucun compromis sur
jérusalem ni pour le droit de notre
peuple à jérusalem d'exercer ses droits
démocratiques
la décision de reporter ces élections
est le résultat d'un accord de
réconciliation entre le parti laïc de
mahmoud abbas le fatah qui siège en
cisjordanie occupée et les islamistes du
hamas qui contrôlent la bande de gaza
mais le plus grand enjeu de ces scrutins
se situe bien à jérusalem est
la zone considérée par les palestiniens
comme la capitale de leur futur état
n'est contrôlé par aucun de ces deux
camps car annexé depuis plus de 50 ans
par israël
un enjeu d'importance donc mais de
nombreux candidats s'offusque de la
décision de mahmoud abbas
des centaines de personnes sont
descendues dans les rues pour dénoncer
ce report en report des élections est
une sorte de vol de la volonté du peuple
palestinien et c'est une soumission à la
volonté de l'occupation nous ne voulons
pas demandé la permission à l'occupation
israélienne pour organiser les élections
dans la jérusalem sainte
l'autre enjeu de ces élections remplacer
une classe dirigeante vieillissante avec
l'espoir d'un changement de direction
le président mahmoud abbas âgé de 85 ans
comptabilise près de 16 ans aux manettes
de l'autorité
en tant que jeune palestinien nous avons
une génération entière qui ne sait pas
ce que signifient les élections qui ne
connaît pas le terme d'élections et qui
n'a pas vécu une vie démocratique
cette génération a le droit d'élire ses
dirigeants de changer et d'être un
partenaire dans la prise de décision
il y en a assez que ceux qui nous
gouvernent et 60 ans il est temps que la
jeunesse palestinienne décide qu'elle
soit un partenaire dans la prise de
décision et elle est un mot à dire une
opinion et qu'elle participe à la
politique
selon ses détracteurs si mahmoud abbas
joue la carte de jérusalem-est pour
reporter ces élections c'est parce qu'il
est confronté à une fronde au sein de
son propre parti
tandis que le hamas cherche lui à
étendre son pouvoir en cisjordanie
occupée
si ces élections on venait à être annulé
l'entente entre les deux principales
factions au pouvoir hamas et fatah
pourrait de nouveau être mise à mal et
on en parle avec un ricardo a beaucoup
au professeur de sociologie apolitique
créée à l'institut de hautes études
internationales et du développement de
genève
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france on l'a entendu
mahmoud abbas justifie sa décision de
reporter les élections législatives par
l'absence de garanties de la part
d'israël sur la tenue du scrutin à
jérusalem est
quel rôle joue réellement israël dans ce
scrutin
je pense que votre reportage bien mis en
évidence le contexte qui précède la
décision de mahmoud abbas c'est à dire
que ces dernières semaines il y a eu des
affrontements très violents entre le
suprématie israéliens contre des
palestiniens
donc ce n'est plus le retour de
roquettes
les aliens latin
les signes hamas lancée dans le sud
d'israël ce qui a ravivé les tensions
dans ce cadre israël
défendre sa déposition pour des raisons
de sécurité comme d'habitude
maintenant c'est un ordre de sécurité
sont discutables à la lumière et nous
avons perdu la connexion avec un
riccardo bocco professeur de sociologie
politique à l'institut de hautes études
internationales et du développement de
genève on tentera de le retrouver il est
avec nous vous avez vous retrouvé
riccardo bocco petits problèmes de
connexion on espère pouvoir poursuivre
cet entretien avec vous les détracteurs
de mahmoud abbas estime que si le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
joue aujourd'hui la carte de jérusalem
est c'est parce qu'il est confronté à
une fronde au sein du fatah son parti
quel est le rapport de force aujourd'hui
au fatah mahmoud abbas se trouve en
mauvaise posture
cd livres décidément un peu compliqué on
reprendra cet entretien un peu plus tard
on part maintenant en israël où l'heure
est au deuil après la bousculade qui a
fait au moins 45 morts la nuit dernière
une catastrophe survenue lors d'un
pèlerinage juif orthodoxe aux mômes est
rond et c'était la première grande
célébration autorisés dans le pays
depuis la levée des mesures de
restriction le premier ministre
netanyahu s'est rendu sur place ce matin
c'est l'une des plus graves catastrophes
de l'histoire d'israël at il affirmé
écouter la catastrophe du mont merron
est l'une des pires catastrophes qui ait
frappé l'état d'israël nous pleurons les
victimes
nous sommes de tout coeur avec les
familles et aussi avec les blessés à qui
nous souhaitons un rétablissement
complet
nous avons vu ici des images déchirantes
des personnes écrasées à mort y compris
des enfants
une grande partie des personnes qui ont
péris n'ont pas encore été identifiés et
je veux éviter de répandre des rumeurs
sur les médias sociaux
car cela déchire le coeur des familles
laissez les autorités travaillent et je
dois également souligné qu'une opération
de sauvetage rapide a été menée par la
police les forces de secours et de
sécurité et nous leur en sommes
reconnaissants ils ont évité une
catastrophe bien plus importante
nous mènerons une enquête minutieuse
sérieuse et approfondie pour nous
assurer qu'une telle catastrophe ne se
reproduise pas je voudrais déclaré une
journée de deuil national dimanche
unissons nous tous à la douleur des
familles et à une prière pour le
rétablissement des blessés
alors qu'il reste on annonce que les
tirs se sont arrêtés chez à la frontière
avec le tadjikistan les forces tadjikes
se retire après des combats meurtriers
ils ont fait au moins 31 morts et plus
de 100 blessés les deux parties qui se
rejettent la responsabilité ont annoncé
hier soir un cessez le feu depuis les
contacts se multiplient pour apaiser la
situation
les revendications territoriales entre
ces deux anciennes républiques
soviétiques sont régulières mais elles
prennent cette fois ci un tournant
inquiétant
la russie dit surveiller de près la
situation chercheur à l'institut
montesquieu david gauzère ne voit lui
pas d'autre issue à ce conflit que la
réussite de pourparlers en les routes
les deux états n'ont pas d'autre choix
que le compromis parce que de s'asseoir
à une table et de négocier le cessez le
feu
puisque nous avons affaire aux deux
anciennes républiques les soviétiques
les plus pauvre de l'ex urss
toutes deux indépendante en 1991 et qui
ont hérité de ses frontières
enchevêtrées de l'époque soviétique
alors nous avons donc autour de ces deux
pays dans l'ouzbékistan qui est cac et
la puissance régionale le local
d'ailleurs dès midi le président ouzbek
shavkat mirziyoyev oppose un cessez le
feu et d'être le médiateur entre les
deux parties qu'elles ghz et tadjik et
puis bien sûr la russie qui à travers la
communauté des états indépendants et de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective a sa carte à jouer
bien entendu
l'union européenne est en pleine
discussion concernant la politique
agricole commune la réforme pour une pac
plus verte doit s'appliquer à partir de
janvier 2023
et c'est pour faire pression sur les
négociations en cours que les
agriculteurs du grand est ont convergé
aujourd'hui vers le parlement européen
un défilé de plus d'un millier de
tracteurs dans les rues de strasbourg ce
qui a occasionné d'importants
embouteillages
les syndicats agricoles redoutent
notamment certaines mesures qui
soumettent les aides à des critères
environnementaux ils dénoncent aussi les
rotations imposer des cultures qui selon
eux amènera une baisse des fourrages à
proximité des fermes
je vous propose d'écouter philippe
clément secrétaire général fnsea grand
test ce qui est en train de se dessiner
en fait c'est une décroissance de
l'agriculture qui va conduire à terme en
fait les importations de denrées
alimentaires bien plus importante que ce
qu'elle ne pourrait être aujourd'hui
alors qu'on a tout pour faire grossir
nos territoires aujourd'hui nous leur
disons surtout faites confiance à vos
paysans et si nous devons effectivement
encore aller un peu plus loin dans tout
ce qui est environnemental pression
écologiste sur nos exploitations nous
ont dit ok c'est ce qu'on fait depuis un
certain nombre de temps déjà mais ça ne
pourra pas se faire sans revenu et sans
accompagnement m c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actu dans une trentaine de
minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative en sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes